.
CONGRATULATIONS FOR HIM.
WE'RE EXCITED FOR HIM.
TO STEPHEN COLBERT AS WELL.
>>> WELCOME TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
A GOOD SIGN AGAINST THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE PANDEMIC.
THE CDC GUIDELINES WILL FOCUS ON
WHAT IT'S SAFE TO DO OUTDOORS
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'VE ALREADY
BEEN VACCINATED.
WEIJIA JIANG IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH THE STORY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS EXPECTED TO
SPEAK ON THE STATE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW, WHAT HAVE YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE NEW GUIDE
AGAINST.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
GAYLE, A FEDERAL OFFICIAL TELL
USES THAT THE LANGUAGE IS NOT
FINAL, BUT THE UPDATED
GUIDELINES WILL STEM FROM ONE
KEY FACTOR, WHETHER SOMEBODY IS
VACCINATED OR NOT.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WILL OUTLINE
WHAT SOMEONE SHOULD AND SHOULD
NOT DO IF THEY ARE VACCINATED
WHEN THEY'RE OUTSIDE.
LIKE WHETHER THEY'RE SHOULD WEAR
A MASK.
WE ALSO EXPECT SOME
CLARIFICATION AROUND PROTOCOLS
IN HEALTH CARE SETTINGS.
THE CURRENT CDC GUIDANCE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT MASKS MAY NOT
BE NECESSARY WHEN YOU ARE
OUTSIDE BY YOURSELF, AWAY FROM
OTHERS OR WITH PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD.
BUT ADVISES TO FOLLOW MASK
MANDATES WHILE OUT IN PUBLIC.
STUDIES IDENTIFIED BY THE
JOURNAL OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES
FOUND LESS THAN 10% OF COVID
INFECTIONS OCCURRED OUTDOORS.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS HAVE SAID
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IT'S THE
GOVERNMENT'S PLACE TO MANDATE
VACCINES.
THIS APPROACH APPEARS TO BE
GROUNDED IN GIVING PEOPLE
INCENTIVES TO GET VACCINATED.
IN OTHER WORDS HERE, ALL OF THE
THINGS YOU DID BEFORE COVID,
THAT YOU CAN DO AGAIN, IF YOU
GET VACCINATED.
IN ITS FIRST FULL DAY IN OFFICE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN ASKED EVERY
AMERICAN TO MASK-UP FOR HIS
FIRST 100 DAYS.
THAT IS SOMETHING HE COULD
RE